welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid today's episode is about fear
specifically my top five list of things
you should fear because science number
one space rocks it could be either an
asteroid or a comet
so space rock is kind of a fitting term
there are millions of these things out
roaming our solar system the ones we
need to keep our eyes on the most are
near-earth objects or Neos no no that's
better as of the making of this video a
little over ten thousand Neos have been
catalogued eight hundred and sixty one
of these have a diameter of at least one
kilometer the kind that caused global
extinction events over fourteen hundred
are classified as potentially hazardous
however these numbers can jump quickly
when those objects get nudged by gravity
thousands of meteors strike the ground
every year most of these guys are really
small but if Russia's any indication in
fact if one is coming for us during the
day we won't even see it we're also
geologically due for another global
extinction event we need to know where
they all are and what they're doing so
we can have some serious advance notice
more science funding please number two
heat this is the number one
weather-related killer in the United
States resulting in hundreds of deaths
per year in 1980 a heat wave claimed the
lives of more than twelve hundred and
fifty people another heatwave in 1995
caused more than 700 deaths in the
Chicago area alone that makes it the
deadliest weather event in Chicago
history in 2003 a record heat wave in
Europe claimed an estimated 50,000 lives
that's why I hide away inside with my
friend the ac3 mosquitoes miss quick
dose most quick dose there we go it's
one of my problem words anyway yeah
mosquitoes they relieve alarm III from
hell not only are they annoying but they
carry diseases malaria West Nile yellow
fever and heartworm just to name a few
become a mosquito hunter and make them
extincted for antibiotic resistant
bacteria
antibiotics oh how I love you over time
though bacteria can build up tolerances
to our medicine in fact penicillin is
still only effective on a few types
we've had to develop stronger ones over
years unfortunately in the last couple
decades antibiotics have been grossly
overused they've been prescribed by
doctors too often for things the human
immune system could do just fine with on
its own then on the flip side we have
people that do need antibiotics but then
don't finish the prescription just
because you feel better doesn't mean all
the bacteria are dead to make matters
worse soap companies are putting them in
all their products to play on the
public's fear of germs it's all doing
more harm than good
I mean tuberculosis is becoming a
problem again because of this stuff when
someone needs an antibiotic to live it
might not even work five global warming
I know a lot of scientists are calling
it climate change these days because
their climate change implies it can also
be global cooling and that's just not
what's happening what well of course my
number five is controversial I'm crazy
like that why is it the people who know
the least know it the loudest global
warming is spinning oh that's why no one
in their right mind would speak that
loudly the average global temperature is
increasing it's not happening as quickly
as some of the hype makes it sound but
it is happening the data is irrefutable
the scientific argument isn't over
whether or not it's happening it's about
whether or not our actions are causing
it but this is the way I look at it
whether we're causing it or not it's
happening and we need to deal with it we
can do this on two fronts first by the
triple our motto reduce reuse recycle in
that order
we can't stop consuming but we can
change how we consume second we could
find an artificial way to do what plants
do with the amount of carbon molecules
going into the atmosphere the trees
aren't really enough to keep the levels
down having giant chemical machines to
pick up the slack might be helpful it
isn't about saving the planet or saving
nature those things will be around long
after we're gone this is about saving
our species keeping the climate the way
it is now is in our best interests so
what's your biggest fear let us know in
the comments if you dare and until next
time remember it's okay to be a little
crazy
you